6 13 on your Monday morning what's  driving you crazy oh boy that I-15  Tropicana project it's about to get real  we've been dropping hints about how big  a deal this construction is going to be  the destruction of the westbound part of  the Tropicana bridge over the I-15  the Nevada Department of  transportation's Tropicana name for the  project now additional word for MDOT  that the I-15 itself is going to be shut  down in both directions around drop 24 7  for several days  we don't yet have the specific dates for  that but we do know it is coming up next  month we're expecting details next week  but I want to give you the heads up that  Tropicana is for real and andotte is  hoping you'll consider downloading the  I-15 Drop app to stay up to date buckle  up drive carefully please put on that  phone and you can join the driving you  crazy conversation at traffic 8 at  8newsnow.com